[Musique]
une école québécoise comme des milliers
d'autres des élèves allumés mais aussi
agitées
nous avons demandé aux candidats des
cinq principaux partis politiques
d'enseigner dans la classe de Madame
Geneviève
alors
l'école primaire les explorateurs à
Laval et public multi-ethniques il est
aussi vétuste comme plus d'une école sur
deux au Québec le gymnase la
bibliothèque les toilettes sont
condamnés le temps de faire des travaux
ici les classes régulières comptent de
plus en plus d'élèves présentant des
défis particuliers le bus cet après-midi
c'est d'amener les élèves à définir
quatre caractéristiques de la France de
bord la classe de 6e année de Madame
Geneviève côté sera notre laboratoire
l'enseignante a assigné une matière à
chaque candidat
et c'est parti
ou presque
mon bouton projet est-ce que vous pouvez
vous asseoir mais pas la même chose
quand même ok vous voulez aller aux
toilettes je laisse aller il faut qu'il
revienne
les réponses il faut enseigner la
matière en moins d'une heure parce qu'on
a déjà été sur les bancs d'école qu'on a
déjà appris cette matière là que c'est
nécessairement facile de la transmettre
il faut aussi assurer un bon climat
pendant que j'avais mon trio féminin sur
le côté j'avais de l'autre côté mon trio
garçon qui s'accusait de tricher en même
temps
que ça déborde chaque candidat
représente une équipe politique qui a sa
vision des choses pour améliorer le
système d'éducation québécoise un
système inéquitable selon le Conseil
supérieur de l'éducation parce qu'il
existe plusieurs vitesses ça c'est
l'éternel débat privé public on veut
mettre fin au système à trois vitesses
retour en classe idéalement il faut
garder les élèves et veiller tout le
monde se lève
là on peut s'asseoir
c'est le temps de leur parler d'élection
moi je sais que le Parti libéral du
Québec en vue d'elle l'élection du 3
octobre vous avez des questions si
jamais vous êtes élu quelle est la
première chose que vous allez changer en
éducation au Québec j'aimerais prendre
concentrer d'avoir des enseignants dans
les classes travailler à la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre des enseignants de donner
davantage de ressources dans les écoles
je veux m'assurer quand vous alliez à
l'école l'air que vous respiriez soit
bon c'est permettre aux gens qui aident
les élèves en difficulté de travailler à
distance pour être capable d'aider des
élèves partout au Québec si vous êtes
élu comment peut-on être certain que vos
promesses seront réalisés quand les élus
font des promesses et qui les tiennent
pas
parce que la population elle a le droit
des chicaner moi j'aime mieux dire que
c'est des engagements plutôt que des
promesses j'ai un devoir de réussir et
de remplir mes promesses faut faire
confiance on peut jamais être certain
l'important c'est l'imputabilité
au-delà des premiers électorales l'école
c'est aussi des enseignants qui marquent
des vies mais moi je les ai trouvés
vraiment à l'humain c'est élever la main
il voulait participer moi je suis devenu
enseignant à cause de Léon Simard un
prof exceptionnel quand je l'ai vu aimé
ça matière mais surtout aimer les élèves
de changer mon parcours un prof au cégep
qui nous a dit que les 1% des plus
riches de la planète détenaient 50% de
la richesse et cette donnée l'homme
avait tellement choqué on y pense pas
assez souvent comment c'est un espace
protecteur pour les jeunes on sait pas
qu'est-ce qu'ils vivent à l'extérieur
enfant et à ce moment-là Pauline mon
enseignante de matériel Seika mais elle
a venait le matin pour donner une pause
mentale à ma mère pour nous faire
traverser pour nous rendre à l'école des
candidats qui s'entendent pour dire que
les élèves particulièrement ayant des
difficultés doivent être une priorité
pour le prochain gouvernement ici Julie
Marceau Radio-Canada Laval